what's going on there reject nation
superman and lois picked back up this
week
we thought it was next week whoops
hopefully this is getting to you guys on
thursday still hey if you could leave a
like that's all we ask right now
all right guys let's watch this
a trust has been established to cover
all living expenses and the title of the
house will be in her name however to
receive your inheritance you must agree
to look after this put your hand in this
box this pendant's destroyed our family
for generations we can end the cycle
you and me
your choice is yours miss alliston hmm
you guys are weird now it's up to you to
finish his life's work
we have a very important guest coming
and i want to show her everything
i don't like everything i don't like
everything at all where'd you get
bizarro's pendant this whole time i
assume that everything that came out of
ali's mouth was a lie but then this
bizarre version of you busted through
the earth's crust and now i'm wondering
what if the two are related
you think this thing could be my shadow
self maybe
what if i didn't have all the facts i
gotta go back through my notes and see
if i missed anything i gotta go back to
journalism school oh please don't make
out in my quinceanera i'm already
nervous enough as it is oh that's right
he's cheating yeah or he cheated
yeah that girl with the bar
superman easy got a lot of broken ribs
how you feeling
he has a lot of broken groups
come on clark's not that hard that
pennant that you took
where is it i gave it to general
anderson during my debriefing what the
[ __ ]
uh you're training this guy jordan
you'd make a terrible spot
i assume i can count on you to keep this
between us
true
either a great-grandpa or a terrible
grandpa depending on how the season goes
everything with you is on a need-to-know
basis you deciding what i need to know
just confirms what i've always known
which is what if you want the truth you
have to find it yourself
i love her have i told everyone that i
loved her
favorite christie's scene yet
mother looks to me like the two of you
are powering up if that thing made me
stronger
why would i have told tag to take it
again private harris said it landed at
his feet you simply told him to run
perhaps you didn't realize it was in his
possession sounds like some north korean
plans you have going on
some anti-american [ __ ] superman
bring me the other superman
and maybe we can discuss getting your
jewelry back
but he needs the jewelry to find the
other superman you dumbass gonna get any
further than he is
stop
not bad
not remarkable either what
this is not some dumb competition
between you and your brother this is a
test to see how special you are that's
messed up right now you're average
yes sir
40 000 push-ups
in 30 seconds
oh my god
no crying you promised
the changing of the shoes is tradition
but if you don't want to no no i can
handle it dad's so excited about all the
symbolic stuff and honestly it's the
only thing keeping me going right now
seeing how happy this all makes him
blitzy find out he's cheating
[Laughter]
whoa okay i got you honey if you fall
i'll always be there to catch you
especially when you don't feel bad about
cheating on george
did anderson at least explain why he
sent them and not you he has it in his
head that i'm using that pendant to
empower myself somehow he refused to
give it to me it's a self-help pendant
you heading home no the mines it turns
out that ammortec scientist that's there
is also one of ali's disciples
i think she's the reason that thing is
here maybe she sent for it you're
choosing facts lois
um
this tea is
delicious
where did you get it
the lobby
your whole belief system it's more about
faith than it is about fact that is
where you're wrong
and i could prove it
no
you are going to ascend
yes
the lobby drugged you
huh all right i feel like you said the
lowest now
dr faulkner
[Music]
oh
[Music]
he was still here yeah he
looked at me and then he just flew off
would he kill her and spare me i i don't
know maybe he's
married to some version of you in his
world
everyone's married to a lois it's seal
slowest backwards
[Laughter]
let the pendant guide her i'm gonna get
the defibrillators just in case
what is that
the truth
congratulations you have ascended oh so
they like die and come back like you
maybe yeah it's like a flatliners thing
you must see something on the other side
[Music]
i want to win this push-up competition
old grandpa to train me
that's it
oh no look i i think honestly at this
point the only way
he's gonna learn to fight a real bad guy
just to support me where's this coming
from john
i just want to see how i stack up
against super boy you know
summer block sure call
yeah rubber all right let's go knock his
block off
kill your brother
hey hey get down here
maybe you're training the wrong kid
finally here's the breaking point okay
one
two three smile
oh
oh
i was me but not me
more like this
sorrow version of myself
[Laughter]
miss allison we believe you may be in
danger the only threat i see is miss
lane kip faulkner was murdered murdered
by whom
he's coming
his bizarro version
hate commercials
insert mid-roll
three two
i'm not gonna let you kill anyone else
i could do this all day
[Music]
wow wow
that's a man of steel [ __ ] right there
[Music]
oh that laser off
you're the opposite of me
[Music]
oh
smart
it's rare clark breathing that heavy man
fight
and fight a plus
matchup oh my god i can't believe that
man actually showed up i was about to
say that
you look um
i think the word that he's searching for
is stunning
you go all aggro at me during training
for what do you hear yourself sometimes
what are you talking about i'm talking
about you for the record i didn't all
aggro to make you look bad i'm just
better than you and i think you should
get used to it because i'm only getting
stronger
wow whoa
this it's a superman of lois or euphoria
the next episode is just gonna be an xk
drug trip
slow motion
you're so sorry we're late oh no
apologies needed we're just getting
started
oh damn it i'm gonna run out check on
the kids in the uh uh bouncy house make
sure there's no broken limbs make
yourselves at home maybe you should take
her name out of your phone to start with
make sure she doesn't get an invitation
i don't know why anybody would willingly
wear those
you want me to like massage them or
something
my strength
the training i know are you doing here i
don't know what else to do what do you
want money you told your girlfriend
battles yeah i did i asked her not to
say anything you think she sold him the
story money's tight i thought you should
know
because i would never do anything to
hurt you kyle
all i wanted was to be with you oh golly
don't turn around please i don't want to
see it yeah
oh thank god i thought i should
stand right she could be right here
though oh god i know this works
it's so much worse
kyle's gotta type
just when they started getting along
everything all right i made a huge
mistake
and uh
i think my family's about to pay for it
hey a lot of kids you had it too
yeah the resemblance between sarah and
your mother is striking
some good genes in the cushing family oh
it's actually the cortez family now
isn't that right babe
um yeah yes your family's just full of
surprises huh
definitely the low point of the evening
thanks for saving me back there
don't worry lawn
it's gonna get so much slower
so much better
it was everything your sister said
different dimension a parallel universe
whatever you want to call it but more
importantly
she's taken over taking over what
exactly the country
maybe even the world
what we're about to start the
father-daughter dance bottom line oh no
we have to do something
this is a trap i don't think so from
chrissy but it could be
[Music]
hey me talking
could you do that
i heard you
can i get a microphone please
thank you all for coming today
you know women in their horror movies
please calm down okay
[Music]
it's not what you think don't lie to me
i i know what i saw you you used some
woman
oh god the girl from the bar
oh but right now we're gonna walk in
there and we're gonna celebrate this
wonderful occasion with our family and
friends i don't think
i don't think i could do it oh man
jesus
wait
[Music]
damn lord are you one strong [ __ ]
goddammit
absolutely how you do
respect
and there's nothing i would change
if i can just keep you by my side all
right
oh
why are you here
hello
to save my world
and yours
ha ha
what's going on man just quit acting
like you know everything
yeah well can you quit lying to my face
i'm not lying
i did just started coming in like a
couple days ago
come on we gotta go tell mom and dad
come on no no no no whoa can we just
look can i just have a little bit longer
can you not be so supportive can i just
get a couple days just to figure this
out before he gets involved
it's sarah i gotta take this okay hey
can we talk about this later please
yeah man
sir never gonna leave the special
his eyes are so red
allie austin will destroy everything you
love your friends
your family
your quinceanera unless you kill her
first
oh
dang
no
no
dark clark man dark clark
it's good this episode was a joke people
goddamn joke yeah
silliness all around
for crying out loud it's 1953.
why do people
[ __ ] about their men cheating it's
better not to know yeah yeah what do you
want come on everybody's got to let off
a little steam man yeah you know men are
at work all day smoking their cigarettes
talking to other men about important man
stuff
can't simply you can't blame a guy a lot
of repression getting married at the age
of 18.
all these societal expectations yeah
wow that was that was shitty
i was really shitty
yeah you learned in one episode about
the woman that kyle's having an affair
with in the next episode she shows up
all manic and ready to destroy it all
have it all crumble how disrespectful a
terrible woman have an affair with shows
where her freaking daughters can see her
yeah it's not how you have affairs with
children yeah that's true even if you're
trying to warn somebody that the affair
is about to come out i feel like you
would not choose that location time and
place well it might not have come out
yeah who says it was to come out yeah
dude lana is so powerful she impressed
me a lot this season
the way she just handled that scene was
so good you like bottling up the pain
having to be like let me not think about
this right now i gotta focus on my
daughter when i was like nine times out
of ten
parents would just be like
in front of the daughter ruined the
quinceanera create some core memory moon
she thought about you know her daughter
at that time and uh
that was a really that was a powerful
moment it was great and and yeah to have
the presence of mind and be like oh no
i'm gonna [ __ ] him out later but good
but right now it's not about that i
spent the whole first half of this
episode setting up that
[ __ ] dan
we're a happy family aren't we we're the
best we're going back to our roots
go by cortez around
[Laughter]
yeah everything was going so well and
then boom shakalaka things went too
short
what are you going to do huh
smallville yeah things happen in
smallville well maybe if everything goes
well with ellie alston kyle could just
blame it on his bizarro self oh yeah
okay so
i don't know anything about ali alston
uh
she's based off of the
actress in the sex cult from uh
smallville right
yes
real life allegory right now
no uh
i think she's getting she's character
from the comics
i don't know the deal with her though i
don't know the specifics
so somehow her world
is some opposite dimension
yes and somehow she's like i'm ruling
the opposites yeah
i'm your tyrant overlord and i'm only
recruiting more people from the other
side
and somehow the thing in the minds
gained physical access
to that dimension
and
through there walked bizarro in a suit
to mislead us that he might be doomsday
yes okay absolutely a big part of the
plan all right and so
bizarro here is not
90 superman animated weird dumb clone no
superman
i love you too
make me my own lois so i can be happy
yeah yeah yeah he's he's just back is
just literally like backwards superman i
think even his dialogue was just like
back masked or something no man you're
way off about that
probably you're right no
i couldn't tell if they were playing his
mouth backwards though i yeah i think he
had a cg mouth for a lot of this so
i think that might be the idea actually
because i feel like you could probably
pretty easily do effects teeth without
needing that that was a good fight
between them too yeah it was good fight
a lot of destruction i love that thing
they have in this show and they punch
someone here's a like
vibrational
yeah like sonic boom
ring thing
we're good with the words we're good
talkers
[Laughter]
talking so good
yeah that was a good fight
um
jonathan is being a [ __ ] john is on a
bender you gotta learn how to control
your drugs man guys you gotta learn how
to be chill so people don't suspect you
bro it's about blending in man come on
stop blending in
yeah be cool man plus he's gonna have to
get a bunch more of that xk now i know
man he's gonna go off the handles he's
gonna have to like you know stock up
become like a full-on junkie
depending on what you use xk for you
could be a vigilante
think about it
oh
i need to stop this person from stealing
a six-pack from the liquor store
and for the next four to six hours i can
now there's only one liquor store
how do i attract more
smoking a little boring tonight
one superman is more than enough it
turns out
except for the special cases but how
often do those happen um
yeah he's uh
i i i appreciate uh the way that they're
characterizing john's uh addiction
that's rooted in a feeling of lack
all that stuff bottled up over being the
best person ever for a season and four
episodes is now finally boiling over or
like you know a lot of people thought
jonathan was like the best person ever
and that was a positive thing they had
to say about the show
[Laughter]
this is bizarro season that's right
would do the opposite and then bizarro
jonathan's going to come through and be
like i had powers but then i gave them
up
i just want to be normal
[Laughter]
yeah
it is the the shadow season for for one
way or another yeah man we all got
shadows kyle's got shadows
uh you know sarah with the depression uh
touching on you know her experience with
that relating to jordan i thought that
was a very lovely scene
jordan getting to uh you know
i don't know
if weirdly i i like what's happened with
jordan because in the first season you
know jordan was like really angsty and
stuff obviously and now
you know it's bizarro he's he's yeah
he's like much more steady now and i
appreciate his his presence it's like
they've taken tour i i now feel more
comforted when jordan is around yeah we
thought he was gonna be like evil man
evil boy yeah
what's that bad superman boy called
oh god i know this one too what was it
yeah
ah
you said it a couple times last season
yeah
[ __ ] what was it
pooper boy
bad boy
bad boy
malfoy bark kent
[Laughter]
and uh chrissy is uh
enjoyable as always
yeah she's finally coming back around
maybe i don't know i don't know if she's
coming if she's if she's doing a mislead
or not every time i go to college so i
see his fight between like i actually
get where christie's come from and the
other half is like screw chrissy
and then if you're a well
done channel
the channel's like what i like is that
you guys talked about both points
well you know what screw that only one
perspective team lois all the way oh
black and white lois always right yeah
never ever doubt lol
never never i would say the same thing
to lois
never doubted you for a second never
doubt lois
uh yeah man
that's uh that was quite twisted for
fields for freaking
just to take a little season break and
be like oh i actually kind of like this
random very realistic cult thing yeah oh
my god it's some weird inter-dimensional
[ __ ]
what a twist yeah for sure
for sure but uh
i like how it ties into
like actually it's not just something
like
here's some superman sword here's lois's
random story well yeah and coming back
to this one after a a few weeks away or
a couple weeks away like it was nice to
be caught by like oh wait she has the
pendant but why oh okay much bigger
things at play
and uh i did think that for the chrissy
you know uh foil part of the plot this
was probably the best articulated i
think it has been thus far i should show
you i agree with that i definitely uh
reckon that how you concur this is the
first time i was like i get where you're
coming from chrissy
i get your perspective
still maybe a little bit of benefit of
the doubt but now we're gonna do ah what
are you gonna do small bowl yes
forget it chuck it's smallville
only in small bowl
it's one pie worth it
my first case in six months
[Laughter]
i don't want to solve it too quick so
i'll start tomorrow
drink my pain away
and go down the bar and talk to tonya
[Laughter]
all right yeah i think we covered
everything i think we covered everything
that is our most comprehensive and well
articulated review touched on everything
briefly and that's all that's required
this was the bizarro version of a normal
review
yeah
superman's mom's really helpful too it's
good that they have those very
comprehensive uploads of their
consciousnesses
i yeah
i think uh the show's woke now because
they swapped out his dad for the mom no
it is woke now isn't it yes oh yeah yeah
well i was really really into
jor-el
yeah it was all about jorel
you just [ __ ] about lara yeah all she
did was birth him
all she did was push
wait wait is that he yeah he was born
naturally that's why i saved him
if he was a test tube baby yeah just let
him burns me like yeah
just let all those things boil
yeah
yeah all right guys well um
don't mistake us joking around for not
liking it's one of my favorite things
about this show is it's so no terrific i
i was so enthralled by this this is so
engaging and i didn't want to end we
have fun with it i love the drama i love
the thrills i love this i i even teared
up during this episode dude i wept like
a school girl getting picked on by a
bunch of
older school girls that is an intense
cry
yeah i feel you i feel you
because
months being a school boy and once i
never cried that's a boy yeah it's not
allowed nah man
don't ever let me catch you crying
as a boy
dude if my son cries i got something i
don't
know
i bet your son cries all the time yeah
you smack that cry right out of me cries
i go
don't be a school girl don't be a school
girl
don't be me every day
this season's about drugs all right guys
well
comment below if you own a necronomicon
if not leave a like
tell them boys at prepper they did an
okay job we're not going to review their
edit today or give notes
so they can put whatever they want yeah
they put footage from a whole other show
like i'm glad you kept everything from
here
but why'd you cut out all of the bizarro
why didn't you cut out all of the parts
you actually responded and reacted to
and leave all the silent moments in the
reaction
that's off on card
all right guys
[Music]